qui s'abstient elle est adoptée à
l'unanimité je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
m'adresser maintenant au groupe CRCE
vous êtes dans votre niche et il y a le
deuxième texte on le démarre c'est une
heure et demie le texte mais si on le
démarre ça veut dire que on essaye de
faire parce que on va pas le couper un
morceau on essaye de faire jusqu'à
l'intervention de la ministre
c'est-à-dire en gros jusqu'à une heure
13h20
on est d'accord pardon
à vous reprendrez après mais par
définition à 14h55 voilà on est d'accord
et bien alors c'est parti
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de la relative à la
maîtrise de l'organisation algorithmique
du travail
présenté par Monsieur Pascal Savoldelli
madame mesdames Katia pour ce poli
Laurence Cohen et plusieurs de leurs
collègues
dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal
Savoldelli auteur de la proposition de
loi pour 10 minutes
le président
[Musique]
merci
c'est comme ça
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
avant de commencer je tiens à saluer les
mobilisations sociales qui se tiennent
partout en France aujourd'hui parce
qu'en réalité les enjeux de cette
réforme des retraites et ceux de
l'ubérisation sont très liés d'ailleurs
je vous le rappelle mes chers collègues
que si les travailleurs des plateformes
étaient requalifiées en salariés ils
permettraient de rapporter 1,45
milliards d'euros à la sécu et son
régime de retraite par leur cotisation
cette proposition de loi que nous
présentons aujourd'hui avec notre groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes s'inscrit vous le savez dans
le prolongement de plusieurs années
d'engagement aux côtés d'acteurs sociaux
sadiko universitaire et politique
mobilisés aux côtés des travailleurs et
travailleuses des plateformes numériques
de travail avec mon collègue Fabien gay
nous avions déjà au sein du collectif
et tais-toi rencontrer des livres
en France qui nous avaient décrit la
réalité mais j'irai dire surtout la
précarité de leur situation
il faut qu'on s'entende là on parle de
travailleurs dit indépendant mais qui
sont dépendants économiquement
cette précarité est le fruit d'un modèle
économique celui du capitalisme de
plateforme dont le cœur de l'action
repose sur un contournement des règles
notamment du droit du travail mais aussi
de la concurrence par le biais du
management algorithmique ce modèle
économique qui entraîne un retour au
temps d'avant
le contrat de travail ou les risques
reposaient uniquement sur les
travailleurs lorsqu'ils n'avaient aucun
pouvoir et où les normes sociales
n'existaient pas en misant sur le
concept d'indépendant à faux statut les
plateformes numériques recréent
l'organisation et la rétribution du
travail à la tâche grâce à un management
algorithmique que je qualifie de brutal
est injustifiable mes chers collègues à
l'heure où nous ne pensons plus le
travail qu'au prisme de la valeur qu'il
produit il est temps de faire le point
sur les coûts de cette production ces
couilles s'appelle Franck page 18 ans
étudiant et coursier pour uber eats ce
soir-là il livrait un repas à vélo
lorsqu'il fut renversé par un camion
avant de trouver la mort
uberis estime que ce décès n'est pas de
sa responsabilité
un dramatique accident de la route mais
pas un accident du travail pourtant cet
itinéraire lui avait été imposé par la
boîte noire l'algorithme ce même
algorithme qui le menaçait de le
déconnecter s'il n'a pas assez vite il
s'agit ici d'un exemple de coursier une
figure parmi les plus visibles de
l'ubérisation pourtant ce modèle touche
à tous les ports le transport les
services à domicile ou encore les
microtravailleurs du clic ces tâcherons
qui se trouvent parfois à l'autre bout
du monde aussi pour réaliser des
bicrostages invisibles pour dire
entraîner la machine mes chers collègues
ce management désincarnés des humanisé
doit cesser il s'assoit sur la loi et
sur le droit des travailleurs le flou de
l'algorithme qui attribue les commandes
évalue leur réactivité calculent le
parcours et le temps de trajet réalisé
ce même flou qui agit comme une épée de
Damoclès au-dessus de la tête des
livreurs les poussant allaient toujours
plus vite ce flou qu'il en laisse le
choix au livreur que la pression de la
la connexion brutale et injustifiable ce
flou rythmé par l'injustifiable un
Floury mais par l'immédiateté allez peu
importe la sécurité et le bien-être de
celui ou celle que l'on note d'une ou
plusieurs étoiles au gré de nos services
la boîte noire de l'algorithme n'est pas
un simple outil dénué d'intention
politique elle est le fruit de décision
de ses fondateurs qui orientent les
comportements des travailleurs inscrits
sur ces plateformes le management
algorithmique constitue de fait pour de
nombreuses plateformes numériques de
travail un outil de contrôle de
direction de sanction le travail que
nous avons porté collectivement au sein
de la mission d'information va également
dans ce sens dans le rapport qui en est
issu fruit d'un trail de plus de trois
mois avec notre collègue la sénatrice
Martine Berthet et grâce à l'audition de
plus de 60 acteurs ce rapport voté à
l'unanimité a permis la formulation de
plusieurs recommandations portant sur la
nécessité de mieux régler mais aussi
d'exiger davantage de transparence des
algorithmes de ces plateformes
numériques de travail
je prends pour exemple la recommandation
numéro 9 qui fait partie des
recommandations qui ont été votées à
l'unanimité
je la cite engage une réflexion pour
adapter le droit au travail aux
spécificités du management algorithmique
et à ses conséquences sur les conditions
de travail
alors que l'algorithme est devenu le
contremaître des temps modernes il
s'agit de rattacher la décision
algorithmique à l'ordre patronale et
contrairement au discours des
plateformes l'algorithme n'est pas un
outil neutre qui serait dépourvus de
subjectivité une décision comprend
toujours une part de subjectivité même
lorsqu'elle est automatisée il subsiste
donc un risque de standardisation de
critères de gestion du personnel mais
également un risque de discrimination si
on intègre dans un algorithme le sexe
l'âge ou encore le lieu de résidence où
je ne sais quelle autre critère cette
présente proposition de loi propose donc
un nouvel angle d'attaque à la
requalification du statut des
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
en effet il faut savoir qu'aucun texte
aujourd'hui aucun texte de droit public
ni de droit privé ne définit à
proprement parler la notion de salariat
ce statut découle directement de la
relation de subordination qui en est
constitutive c'est pourquoi cette
proposition de loi tant à mettre à jour
la relation de subordination existante
entre l'algorithme qu'on pourrait
appeler de l'ordre et le travailleur ou
la travailleuse de la plateforme
numérique il est extrêmement important
de vrais vers l'ouverture de la boîte
noire de l'algorithme son opacité est
problématique et en particulier pour les
travailleurs et travailleuses concernés
un rapport du Défenseur des droits et de
la CNIL datant de mai 2020 alerte déjà
sur cet angle mort du débat public les
exemples de dérives et de discrimination
par le biais des algorithmes sont
nombreux et sur une grande diversité de
plateformes différentes on a eu des cas
par exemple de déconnexion abusives chez
les plateformes comme deliveroo suite à
des mobilisations sociales pouvant
s'apparer s'apparenter à la répression
syndicale comme cela avait été documenté
par cash investigation ou encore de
discrimination femmes hommes à
l'embauche chez Amazon et ce ne sont que
quelques exemples parmi tant d'autres
l'un des leaders de la des chauffeurs
VTC Brahim Ben Ali nous disait hier que
le discours d'Hubert pour répondre à
leur demande d'une plus grande
transparence algorithmique consistait
alors répondre je les cite on va pas
vous donner le secret de notre
algorithme ce serait comme donner la
recette de Coca-Cola d'accord mais le
secret des affaires peut pas contourner
un nécessaire encadrement quand il
touche aux conditions de travail et aux
risques de discrimination nous ne
parlons pas là d'une boisson nous
parlons de vie humaine de centaines de
milliers de travailleurs et
travailleuses nous allons vers la fin de
la hiérarchie du salariat tout en
maintenant une subordination accrue et
renouvelée dans l'esprit de la start-up
chacun devient son propre employeur une
entreprise d'ailleurs de soi et bien
posons-nous la question où est l'utilité
sociale d'un travail de quoi parle-t-on
avec la valeur travail et j'irai même de
la valeur humaine alors mes chers
collègues ne faisons pas comme les
avions n'attendons pas que l'avion
scrache pour en ouvrir la boîte noire
l'algorithme n'est plus ou moins qu'un
contrat de travail mais un contrat dont
les premiers concernés n'ont pas accès
aux informations les plus fondamentales
qui concernent directement leurs
conditions de travail les travailleuses
et les travailleurs des plateformes
numériques ont pourtant besoin de codes
sources autrement dit d'être informé de
l'intervention humaine qui se trouve à
la source de l'os subordination à cet
ordre algorithmique cette machine qui
décide à quel moment vous êtes rentable
en faisant de ces travailleuses et ses
travailleurs des tâcherons corvéables à
merci l'algorithme c'est aujourd'hui
investi dans tous les pans de notre
société qu'il s'agisse de parcoursup
pour les étudiants avec tous les
problèmes de sélection qu'il a pu poser
ou encore la sélection de curriculum
vitité dans les cadres dans le cadre de
recrutement dans certaines entreprises
dont la sélection fait parfois preuve de
discrimination il est donc crucial de
regarder de près ce qui s'y passe c'est
tout le sens de cette proposition de loi
ainsi l'article indéfini l'algorithme
sur le plan juridique comme pouvoir de
direction et de contrôle lorsqu'il joue
un rôle de subordination d'un employeur
ayant un impact sur ses employés
l'article 2 de notre proposition de loi
engage la responsabilité de l'employeur
en prévoyant l'O pour ce dernier de
démontrer que l'algorithme n'est pas
source de discrimination et l'article 3
précise la différence entre une simple
plateforme de mise en relation et une
plateforme jouant un rôle effectif
d'employeur notre projet de loi propose
humblement de maintenir ouvert le débat
sur cette question sans prétendre pour
autant être la réponse à tout il s'agit
avant tout de maintenir le débat ouvert
sur le plan national car nous savons que
le projet directive européenne sur cette
question va dans le même sens cette
directive constitue une belle avancée
pour les droits des travailleurs des
plateformes confirmant une présomption
de salariat et permettant de lutter
contre le travail dissimulé et nous nous
la défendons pour autant la France se
pose davantage comme un défenseur
aujourd'hui encore des lobbys des
plateformes on a témoigné l'affaire et
en témoignant encore l'affaire
hubert-fice nous devons maintenir la
pression car ce management algorithmique
est aujourd'hui le plus grand cheval de
Troie néolibéral qui finira par
s'inviter dans toutes les formes de
management au travail donc je vous
invite fortement mes chers collègues à
voter cette proposition de loi
le 3 froidvilliers cette proposition de
loi la froid sonoré à reconnaître les
droits des travailleurs des plateformes
avant même la fin du processus
législatif européen cette proposition de
loi constitue un nouveau jalon important
vers un chemin qui reste encore long
pour protéger à la fois les travailleurs
et les travailleuses des plateformes
mais également et je tiens à le dire
également pour protéger les entreprises
et les commerces qui sont en proie à une
concurrence déloyale du point de la part
des plateformes numériques de travail
tout cela il faut respecter les règles
du jeu donc
oser
osons lui donner les moyens d'accomplir
son objectif donc évidemment je vais
vous dire que je vous appelle à fouetter
cette proposition là merci de votre
attention et surtout à ceux qui sont
présents
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Katia pour ce poli
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales pour 10 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
surveillance constante l'évaluation
permanente des performances
l'application automatique des décisions
sans intervention humaine l'interaction
des travailleurs avec un système et la
faible transparence des algorithmes
telles sont les éléments constitutifs du
management algorithme selon le Bureau
international du Travail la proposition
de loi de notre collègue Pascal ça vole
Delhi qui travaille avec Fabien gay
depuis plusieurs
années sur ce sujet et des membres du
groupe communiste républicains citoyen
écologique
à bord de cette réalité l'utilisation de
l'algorithme pour l'organisation du
travail et la gestion de la main
d'oeuvre déjà bien présente dans le
monde du travail elle est pourtant
ignorée de notre droit l'apparition des
plateformes numériques a entraîné une
rupture technologique en permettant à
une multitude d'acteurs d'être mis en
relation en temps réel elle a aussi
initié un bouleversement de
l'organisation du travail par recours à
des algorithmes dans les secteurs des
VTC de la livraison de marchandises en
véhicules à deux roues les travailleurs
quoique formellement indépendants sont
soumis à un degré élevé de contrôle et à
une nouvelle forme de dépendance même
s'ils peuvent choisir de se connecter ou
non à l'application et à quel moment ils
le font ils sont en réalité privée
d'autonomie dans la réalisation de leur
prestation ces travailleurs précaires et
contraintes recourir à des formes assez
formes d'emploi cumulent les fragilités
faibles revenus protection sociale
incomplète absence de garantie en
matière de temps de travail et de droit
au repos forte exposition au risque
professionnel isoler ils sont de
surcroît mis en compétition permanente
par les algorithmes ces derniers
apparaissent dès lors comme des boîtes
noires sur lesquelles les travailleurs
n'ont qu'une prise ni aucune visibilité
cette plateformisation de l'économie se
généralise à l'ensemble du monde du
travail les algorithmes sont déjà de
plus en plus utilisés pour gérer les
ressources humaines au sein des
entreprises intervention dans le
processus de recrutement la gestion des
évolutions de carrière ou l'évaluation
des salariés des logiciels peuvent ainsi
analyser et comparer les comportements
des candidats lors d'entretien de
recrutement si elle permet des gains de
productivité cette gestion algorithmique
du travail et porteuse de risques de
surveillance abusives et généralisée de
perte d'autonomie et de discrimination
accrue le sentiment d'aliénation qui
peut alors gagner les travailleurs et
facteurs de risque psychosociaux en
outre cette gestion algorithmique tant à
des responsabiliser les employeurs et à
priver les acteurs du dialogue social de
leur rôle en matière de détermination
des conditions de travail
les risques sont d'autant plus
importants que le fonctionnement des
algorithmes peut échapper aux employeurs
eux-mêmes qui ont souvent recours à des
solutions technologiques développées en
externe dans son rapport du 29 septembre
2001 sur l'ubérisation de la société
Pascal Savoldelli a considéré qu'un
algorithme n'était pas seulement une
suite d'opération permettant de traiter
des volumes importantes données mais
bien une chaîne de responsabilité
humaine quel que soit son degré
d'automatisation la gestion
algorithmique engage la responsabilité
de personnes auxquelles il devrait être
possible de se référer il a ainsi
préconisé d'adapter le droit du travail
aux spécificités du management
algorithmique et assez conséquences sur
les conditions de travail la proposition
de loi traduit cette conviction afin de
reprendre le contrôle de l'organisation
algorithmique
certes les algorithmes constituent une
aide considérable pour améliorer
l'organisation des entreprises et
exonération et exonérer les travailleurs
de tâches parfois répétitives et
contraignantes toutefois lorsqu'ils sont
utilisés à des fins d'organisation du
travail il devrait toutefois être
encadrés et contrôlé ainsi les
travailleurs devraient être informés de
l'utilisation de ces outils et avoir
accès à leurs modalités de
fonctionnement dès lors qu'ils affectent
leurs conditions de travail quant à
l'employeur il doit demeurer entièrement
responsable des décisions qu'il prend
dans l'entreprise l'utilisation
d'algorithmes devraient considérer comme
un simple outil d'aide à la décision
l'article premier inscrit donc dans donc
les décisions des employeurs prises à
l'aide de moyens technologiques parmi
les décisions relevant de leur pouvoir
de direction il renforce l'accessibilité
du contenu des décisions l'information
du salarié sur les motivations des
décisions le concernant et lui permet de
demander qu'une nouvelle la décision
soit prise par un être humain par
ailleurs l'article 2 vise à assurer le
respect du principe de non
discrimination dans l'utilisation des
algorithmes par les triglonais qu'ils
opèrent et les recommandations qu'ils
formulent en fonction d'un ensemble de
critères les algorithmes peuvent
conduire à des discriminations des
travailleurs contraire à la loi celle-ci
peuvent même survenir indépendamment de
la volonté de l'employeur une telle
situation s'est déjà produite en 2017
l'entreprise amazon a dû renoncer à
l'utilisation d'un algorithme pour le
recrutement de salariés car il induisait
une discrimination à l'embauche en
privilégiant les hommes aux femmes
le logiciel s'appuyait sur une base de
données recensant les CV reçus par
l'entreprise depuis 10 ans qui
comprenait une grande majorité de CV
d'hommes l'algorithme en a déduit que
les candidats masculins étaient
préférables et rejeter les candidatures
féminines
face à de tels risques l'employeur doit
être responsable des outils
technologiques qui l'utilisent pour le
recrutement ou la gestion des salariés
dans l'entreprise la protection des
travailleurs contre toutes les formes de
discrimination au travail ne serait être
affaibli par l'utilisation d'outils
technologiques pour l'organisation des
entreprises c'est pourquoi l'article 2
pose le principe selon lequel en cas de
litige l'employeur doit apporter la
preuve que les outils qu'ils utilisent
qui l'utilisent ne sont pas sources de
discrimination la proposition de loi
s'attache enfin à mettre en lumière la
situation des travailleurs plateformes
qui est le résultat le plus visible de
l'influence des algorithmes sur le monde
du travail la qualification
qualification excusez-moi juridique de
ces travailleurs dont le Sénat déjà eu
l'occasion de débattre à plusieurs
reprises est une question d'ordre public
social
l'ambiguïté de leur situation lorsque
l'algorithme de la plateforme joue un
rôle essentiel dans l'organisation du
travail donne lieu à un cont abondant
auquel la réponse des juridictions n'est
pas univoque plusieurs décisions de la
Cour de cassation penchées dans le sens
de la requalification salariée de
livreur à vélo de chauffeurs de VTC mais
elles n'ont pas une portée absolue à
défaut de leur reconnaître le statut de
salarié le législateur a progressivement
troyé depuis 2016 des droits spécifiques
aux travailleurs de plateforme en
prévoyant que lorsqu’une plateforme
détermine les caractéristiques de la
prestation de service et fixe sont pris
elle a une responsabilité sociale à
l'égard des travailleurs indépendants
recourants à ses services en particulier
la loi d'orientation des mobilités du 24
décembre 2019 et les ordonnances du 21
avril 2021 et du 6 avril 2022 ont posé
le cadre d'un dialogue social entre
travailleurs indépendants et plateformes
dans les secteurs de la mobilité les
premières avancées obtenues dans ce
cadre ne sont pas négligeables toutefois
les droits spécifiques progressivement
raccorder à ces travailleurs ont surtout
ils pourraient fait de les enfermer dans
un statut d'indépendant amélioré et de
conforter le modèle des plateformes qui
reposent sur le contournement du droit
du travail et le dumping social ces
réponses à l'ubérisation ne sont donc
pas à la hauteur le statut d'indépendant
n'est pas adapté à la situation des
travailleurs précaires qu'ils soient
livreurs à vélo ou chauffeur de VTC et
ne correspond pas à la réalité des
relations entre ces travailleurs et les
plateformes si le même débat existe dans
toute l'Europe d'autres pays ont apporté
des réponses plus audacieuses en Espagne
par exemple la loi Ryder entrée en
vigueur en août 2021 prévoit une
présomption de salariat pour les
livreurs à deux roues et un droit
d'accès des travailleurs à l'algorithme
afin de conforter le mouvement juridique
jury prudentiel en faveur de la
requalification de certains travailleurs
de plateformes l'article 3 de la
proposition de loi vise à introduire
distinction entre d'une part les
véritables opérateurs de mise en
relation et d'autre part les plateformes
d'emploi qui exercent un contrôle
juridique et économique sur les éléments
essentiels de la relation travail en
conséquence un travailleur opérant en
lien avec une plateforme devrait relever
sous le contrôle du juge d'une relation
de travail salarié et non du régime de
la responsabilité sociale des
plateformes en facilitant pour ceux qui
le souhaitent la reconnaissance de leur
lien subordination avec les plateformes
le texte a pour objectif de permettre à
ces travailleurs de bénéficier d'une
rémunération horaire minimale d'un
encadrement des ruptures ainsi que d'une
protection sociale appropriée un mot du
sort des travailleurs de plateforme sans
papier ceci ont fait l'objet déconnexion
massive à la suite de la signature par
les plateformes de livraison d'une
charte relative à la lutte contre la
forme la fraude et la sous-traitance
irrégulière en outre ces travailleurs ne
peuvent pas faute de bulletin de salaire
à leur nom bénéficier des dispositions
de la circulaire du 29 novembre 2012
dites circulaires Valls permettant la
régularisation pour le travail madame la
ministre allez-vous permettre à ces
travailleurs de sortir de l'impasse la
commission des affaires sociales a
rejeté cette proposition de loi à titre
personnel je le regrette et espère que
nos débats permettront de fédérer celles
et ceux qui au sein de cette Assemblée
partage nos inquiétudes je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et
maintenant madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
sociales Philippe mouillé monsieur le
sénateur parce qu'elle savo-délit madame
la rapporteur Cathy a poursu poli
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
ouvrons ce jour les débats sur la
proposition de loi relative à la
maîtrise de l'organisation algorithmique
du travail de Monsieur Pascal savaudelli
madame Cathy a poursu poli et de leurs
collègues du groupe communiste
républicains citoyens et écologiste je
vous prie d'excuser l'absence du
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft tout
d'abord l'impact des algorithmes sur
l'organisation du travail est un enjeu
important dont le gouvernement prend
toute la mesure ce gouvernement est le
ministre du Travail sont très attentifs
aux mutations sociales entraîner par la
révolution numérique nous avons lancé en
décembre dernier les assises du travail
visant à engager une réflexion sur pour
le rapport au travail la qualité de vie
et la santé au travail ainsi que la
démocratie au travail ces assises ont
réuni de manière large les partenaires
sociaux des personnalités qualifiées et
des universitaires ces travaux ont
également inclus les questions liées aux
management par les algorithmes et des
propositions seront formulées dans le
rapport qui sera rendu dans les
prochains jours par ailleurs nous
agissons également pour mieux réguler
les relations entre les travailleurs des
plateformes et les plateformes
elles-mêmes ces dernières années un
cadre juridique a été mis en place pour
permettre l'émergence du dialogue social
dans le secteur des plateformes de VTC
et de livraison pour leur permettre de
négocier un socle de droit ainsi nous
saluons et je le salue en tant
qu'ensienne rapporteur sur le texte
législatif l'accord instaurant un revenu
minimal de la course pour le secteur des
VTC qui témoignent de la dynamique
engagée pour l'amélioration des droits
sociaux des travailleurs de ce secteur
d'activité bien sûr face aux
métamorphoses du travail qu'implique la
révolution numérique il faut accompagner
et adapter notre modèle ainsi cette
proposition de loi pose une question
importante celle de notre rapport aux
avancées technologiques il est donc
important de rappeler que les contenus
de ces technologies n'ont pas de
direction naturelle rien ne les destine
en soi à contraindre le travail plutôt
qu'à l'améliorer il nous revient de leur
donner une intention de choisir comment
mettre ces technologies à notre service
disons-le clairement notre optimisme
vis-à-vis de ces technologies n'est pas
contradictoire avec une vigilance sur la
forme des progrès qu'elle permet à cet
égard et contrairement à ce que certains
voudraient faire croire nous sommes
attentifs à ce que l'homme continue de
réguler et d'encadrer le travail pour ne
pas céder à une administration ou une
gouvernance par les nombres la question
qui doit nous animer n'est pas de
combattre les algorithmes mais bien de
savoir comment mettre les algorithmes en
ou comment mettre les
algorithmesourdines mais comment être
sûr qu'ils sont à notre service pour une
meilleure organisation du travail je
tiens à exprimer que nous ne pensons pas
que cette proposition de loi donne une
réponse satisfaisante à cette question
en effet cette proposition de loi en
proposant d'adapter les règles du droit
du travail pour permettre pour mieux
prendre en compte la gestion
algorithmique pose en question en
réalité une question qui m'est plus de
difficultés sur la table qu'elles n'ont
résout à cet égard le gouvernement n'est
pas la seule elle pensait puisque
mercredi dernier la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat a rejeté
cette proposition de loi ainsi la
commission partage notre diagnostic sur
l'utilité des dispositifs proposés
revenons rapidement sur ces dispositifs
présentés dans trois articles d'abord le
premier article propose de considérer
les décisions ayant un effet sur les
salariés et prises par un algorithme
comme relevant de l'exercice du pouvoir
de direction et de contrôle de
l'employeur dans l'idée de le
responsabiliser davantage face à une
décision qui qu'il aurait en réalité
délégué un algorithme cette proposition
n'ajoute en réalité rien à l'existant de
fait la responsabilité de l'employeur
n'est en aucun cas écarté par une prise
de décision automatisée algorithmique
pour le dire autrement un ordre passait
par algorithme n'en n'est pas moins un
indice de subordination à l'employeur
qui pourra être pris en compte par le
juge pour prononcer une éventuelle
requalification de la relation de
travail il en va de même de l'autre
proposition faite dans ce premier
article de garantir l'accès du salarié
aux décisions qu'il concerne en matière
disciplinaire et à leur motivation dans
l'idée d'instaurer une voie de recours
humaine aux sanctions automatisées de
fait le code du travail encadre déjà les
procédures disciplinaires des
entreprises et probablement mieux que ne
le permettrait cette proposition plus
précisément il n'est en droit du travail
pas possible d'appliquer une sanction
disciplinaire de manière automatique par
un algorithme d'autre part les voies de
recours qui ne sont pas conditionnés les
voies de recours ne sont pas
conditionnées au fondement de la
décision ainsi si une sanction est prise
sur le fondement de données récoltées
par un algorithme les voies de recours
ne sont pas différentes d'une décision
prise sur la base d'informations
purement humaine
pour ne donner qu'un exemple face à une
sanction le salarié peut
systématiquement saisir le conseil de
prud'hommes qui peut ensuite annuler la
sanction si elle n'est pas justifiée à
cet égard la proposition risque donc de
rendre plus confus le droit existant
plutôt que de l'améliorer ensuite le
deuxième article propose qu'en cas de
litige relatif à une discrimination
indirecte les modalités de preuve soient
aménagées il reviendrait ainsi à
l'employeur d'apporter la preuve de
l'absence de discrimination le motif est
bien sûr louable nous savons que les
algorithmes par définition aveugles à
toute autre principe que l'optimisation
sous contrainte peuvent entretenir des
biais discriminants mais là encore je ne
saurais dire à quel besoin cette
proposition répond puisque le code du
travail est unanime aucun salarié ne
peut être sanctionné licencié ou faire
l'objet d'une mesure discriminatoire
directe ou indirecte sur la base de
certains critères et ce peu importe le
fondement de la discrimination et les
moyens par laquelle cette discrimination
se produit la charge de la preuve est
déjà aménagée au bénéfice du salarié des
lorsqu’elles allègue d'une
discrimination y compris si sa
discrimination est le résultat de
l'utilisation d'un algorithme enfin le
dernier article pose propose
d'introduire dans la loi la
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation en
matière de requalification de la
relation entre un travailleur et une
plateforme en écartant la qualification
de plateforme de mise en relation
des leurres que celle-ci exerce un
contrôle juridique et économique sur les
éléments essentiels de la relation de
travail notamment par les moyens
technologiques ou traitement automatisés
là encore vous indiquez souhaitez
inscrire dans la loi le cadre
jurisprudentiel existant de longue date
sur la définition du lien de
subordination cependant la Cour de
cassation n'a jamais retenu que
l'exercice d'un contrôle juridique et
économique y compris par des moyens
technologiques ou traitement automatisé
permettez de caractériser une relation
de travail à nouveau la solution
proposée ne répond pas à l'ambition
affichée elle viendrait remettre en
cause l'équilibre jurisprudentiel sur
l'appréciation des critères de
subordination elle ne prend également
pas en compte le cadre juridique défini
depuis plusieurs années pour créer une
véritable responsabilité sociale des
plateformes et dont les acteurs se sont
déjà emparés en conclusion comme je l'ai
dit si nous partageons l'esprit de cette
proposition de loi nous n'en
reconnaissons pas l'utilité et ne
pouvons le considérer comme une solution
au management algorithmique la priorité
n'est donc pas de se précipiter sur
l'encadrement des algorithmes au risque
de le faire maladroitement voire contre
les protections déjà offertes par le
Code du travail dont l'application
protège les travailleurs il s'agit de
redoubler de vigilance pour la bonne
application du droit et de réfléchir
plus avant à ce que l'on attend des
algorithmes au travail je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
14h50 pour la suite de l'examen de ce
texte la séance est suspendue